Jim reefer version where'd you grow up
Ontario California Ontario and tell me
about your family you had both of your
parents brilliant just my father got
molested as I was a kid you did just
your father yeah and your molested
weighed like six or seven right my mom
my mom died my dad
how long do this went on until I was
about 13 then I learned how to kill
things so I start killing animals eating
eating animals what kind of animals dogs
and cats you would kill dogs and cats
and you go and eat them how did how do
you well why would you eat aunt Doris
and cats instead because I was so angry
and I didn't know how to tell anyone
that I was getting molested
so you're living on the street down on
Skid Row yes do every time yes I do too
so you'll catch a dog or a cat and he'll
do what eating mice getting alive in an
idiom how did you cook it on the
barbecue grill you're a girl yes I did
how many dogs and cats have you done
this - oh about a couple hundred
[Music]
what do you make money on the street in
any way No
do you use any of the drugs that are
there right no honey ain't drugs so your
your mom what happened to your mom I'm
gonna cut this up we're gonna have the
kid I was like six months old my mom
killed herself
you know what the details you know why
you know I don't
so you never had them over you did all
the Weiner know your dad was molesting
you yeah
did you who are schooling it here went
up to the party that's the seventh grade
you know what the youth of dougherty
caught me didn't close to you to animals
that's right
they caught me being cool T to animals
here's the cops yeah do they send me
your thority I stayed there about six
years cuz I kept getting in trouble how
many years have you been living on the
street a lot of six did you have a job I
never had a job you went from like Youth
Authority which is like prison for the
kids - where - on the streets and they
had nowhere else to go so you got out he
got out at age 17 oh you know I'm 30
you're 30 do you have any friends no
family no was your dad still around
No
give-give any hope for your future you
see anything down the road at my place I
don't know
[Music]
it's probably to go through life do you
have you been to therapy have you been
to any program I go to the psych I've
been to the site but they just give me
medication these okay no I take it no no
your brothers and sisters no you just me
what do you think might might help your
situation I don't know what to do I
don't know what to do it's stuck it's
stuck here
I eat out of the trash I don't wear I
not asked my buddy
Oh what else do you know your situation
so without an education without job
experience at that I've had a childhood
oh how do you looking back at your
childhood you must have been terrible
right that was terrible man I don't know
what else to do man I tried to talk
about it to keep it away from me man
which side still haunts me
I was going to the site to see the site
once a month and I just try to talk
about it so I don't have to do it if not
I just eat out the trash
what can I keep you in high school I
don't know
there I guess it's going to others
really didn't really bother people cuz I
I bit this girl here because I just
wanted to be left alone you know and
they kept bothering me teasing me
causing the are you comin Lester I you
got molested you know it bothers me you
know they're making fun of it yeah
this heart explains because it's like
feel like I'm going through it all over
again and what else to do but to talk
you don't know what you went through as
a child that's awful yeah I don't know
those dudes I feel like some time I'm in
a daze you know all of them coming and
going you know
I'm alone
you get depressing cuz everyday living
in the outside in a tent around a
bathroom you don't have nothing
well I'm Christian or nothing I don't
know what else to do
how do you do what do you see life this
is life sucks man sucks man
did you how do you view other people -
dude I'm Johnson find other people that
you like her no no I don't not tried not
to tell you because I see that I know
that I'm I'm difficult already as it is
you know it's hard for me to make
friends I'm not a friendly type of guy
you know this is what I've been through
you know and it's like it's hard to
trust people and I just wish I couldn't
go ahead and trust a person but I can't
you know know what the parents you'd
have it didn't no no it's just like more
so I see them getting close as I moved
back because I don't trust you
oh it's hard to trust someone very hard
to trust someone
you ever had relationships with no
further on that no you know if that
experience with your dad which is a
childhood set me straight or gay I don't
do sex at all
I use my hand sorry to say use my hand
so scared to trust somebody I don't want
to do me like my dad gave me unless me
you know so I kind of just they keep my
distance
can you even envision a different kind
of life if you hadn't had your dad
molesting you didn't have your mom pass
away interviewed you even imagine what
that might be like for you no I don't
know I'm gonna know what to have my life
is having a place to stay at I don't
know far as I know it's a jailhouse it's
all I know I wish it was a happier place
than that I go to cheer no I'm okay I
survive
I know what else is new me to to talk
like I said I wish it was just something
better I don't know anything I don't
know how to do anything so that makes it
even rougher coming your no skills no
skills education no I barely know how to
read because of all that you have no
hope
yeah I only know what to tell next
person I wouldn't know I wouldn't know
what to tell the next project cuz I
don't I don't even know myself
if you could say something to your dad
what would you say I'll [ __ ] kill your
ass right now but can is dead
[ __ ] that [ __ ] he get to me man just
wished it man it never happened to me at
all I wish I could've just been a normal
kid you know that's what I would tell
him because all this is like
it's so stressful man it's just nothing
not having nowhere to go and have it no
one know I have a news to go or people
to talk to hurts it hurts man hey that
[Music]
will be fine coming here helps you by
talking with me okay okay all right you
well thank you so much for sharing your
story okay my name's mark you can come
back anytime okay
you